Do you remember this question that Greg asked? Well, the answer is, during your
teenage years, this is another time when your amount of REM sleep increases.
So, does the amount of neural growth. The human brain is still growing into
early adulthood. Neurons though, never stop growing, even if the rate of growth
does slow over time. The biggest region of brain growth in adolescents occurs
in the frontal lobes. Which allow us to think abstractly, plan, control
impulses and to think critically, and scientifically. Teenagers are much more
likely to do impulsive and risky things, because their frontal lobes are still
growing and maturing. Driving a car really, really fast while not wearing a
seatbelt, or skateboarding off of a 5-foot stair handrail seems perfectly
reasonable to many teenagers. The brain isn't our only change during
adolescence though. Let's go check in with Susan, who's going to explain the
other physical changes that we go through.